Compressor Head - The Trailer, Season 2
COLT MCANLIS: "Compressor
Head" is a movement.
BRIAN GRADY: It's a
show about the movement.
COLT MCANLIS: Well, no, it's
a data compression revolution.
BRIAN GRADY: The
magic of compression.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLT MCANLIS: Ow!
[BLEEP], dude.
You know, people
are writing apps.
Everyone's so busy to
write the next big thing
that they forget about this
very simple concept of data
compression.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, man!
Let's do it!
COLT MCANLIS: Go!
And how important
it is to get data
to people as fast as possible.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah!
Finish strong, finish strong.
COLT MCANLIS: It's
something that I
wanted to rekindle-- a love
for this sort of lost computer
science art.
SPEAKER 2: There's a
funny story about that.
SPEAKER 3: You
need to tell them.
Tell them.
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
BRIAN GRADY: Next 5
billion users in the world
are going to have
limited bandwidth.
COLT MCANLIS: People
need to be aware of how
they're using their data.
BRIAN GRADY: You can't get
this information anywhere else.
COLT MCANLIS: We try to
make it super fun to learn
something super boring.
And we tackle some
pretty complex topics.
Take entropy for example.
And, you know what?
"Compressor Head" is just fun.
[LAUGHING]
Every talk I give publicly,
every conference I
go to, I've had someone stop me.
And they've said, thank you
for making "Compressor Head."
Something about the way
you described it-- it
just picked up with me.
Thank you for "Compressor Head."
Like, that's humbling.
I mean, it's just humbling.
We just had to do it again.
I mean, that's why
we do these things is
for developers out there.
You're looking at
the inner workings
of science here, folks.
BRIAN GRADY: There's
other surprises
that we can't
necessarily go into here
because it's a family show.
COLT MCANLIS: My
name is Colt McAnlis,
and this is "Compressor Head."
The End